buenas tardes es un panorama cada vez
más complejo más oscuro para el primer
ministro boris johnson que sigue
perdiendo credibilidad de autoridad la
de hoy ha sido una jornada llena de
sorpresas primero porque el gobierno
tiene las mayorías en la cámara de los
comunes y los diputados de los partidos
de todos los partidos los pocos que
estaban en el debate por unanimidad y
sin debate
acordaron sin votación acordaron que
boris johnson debe ser investigado lo
que nos muestra también el descontento
del partido del primer ministro el
conservador con su líder ahora lo que
sigue es que un comité especial del
parlamento establecerá si johnson mintió
deliberadamente o no al parlamento a sus
colegas recordemos que en repetidas
oportunidades el primer ministro negó
haber asistido a estas fiestas del
escándalo queda un instruir pese a que
ya scotland yard la policía lo ha
multado por la asistencia a una el día
de su cumpleaños el 19 de junio del año
2020 si johnson es encontrado culpable
sería gravísimo sin precedentes
y lo dejaría con muy pocas opciones y
prácticamente al borde de tener que
renunciar ha sido tal el malestar del
partido conservador que cada vez empieza
a distanciarse más de su líder que hoy
uno de los diputados más veteranos de
este partido aliado de boris johnson
steve baker dijo que johnson ya cumplió
con la admisión por la que fue elegido y
debe irse es el momento de irse
entretanto también el partido de
conservador tory está a la espera de los
resultados de las elecciones de dos
semanas las elecciones regionales para
establecer si el tiempo de boris johnson
ha llegado o no a su final